the oscar-winning director James Cameron
offered this observation on visual
effects it takes hundreds of men and
women to create the magic of the films
nominated for Best Visual Effects they
work with computers making art out of
ones and zeros a computers don't make
visual effects people do they are
artists people who dream with their eyes
wide open
they breathe life into characters in
worlds both beautiful and terrifying
these unforgettable images are put on
the screen by blood sweat tears and
software but most of all by the driving
force of unbridled human imagination for
Best Visual Effects the nominees are
for AI artificial intelligence Dennis
Muren Scott Farrar Stan Winston and
Michael and Terry
for the Lord of the Rings the Fellowship
of the Ring
Jim Rygel Randall William cook Richard
Taylor and Mark Stetson
for Pearl Harbor Erik Brevik John
Frazier Ed Hirsch and Ben's snow
and the Oscar goes to
Jim Rygel Randall William cook Richard
Taylor and Mark Stetson for the Lord of
the Rings the Fellowship of
wheezes first Oscars to Jim rygiel
Randall William cook into Max Jetson
this is Richard Taylor second Oscar
tonight they produced 1000 suits of
armor
mm unfair
and over 2200 pairs of prosthetic Hobbit
feet for the film
I wanna say thank you to junior token
who wrote it Peter Jackson who directed
it newline who supported it my wife and
family Teresa Sara and Jackson who
supported me and the amazing artists at
wet a digital in New Zealand here it is
we wanted to wave a tapestry of
heightened reality with the special
effects visual effects on Lord of the
Rings and a tribute has to go to Alex
funky dop of the miniatures department
carla fried who was there with us from
the beginning the wonderful people at
the wetter workshop Mary McLaughlin John
Bester
Jason Daugherty and Gena ASA Vito for
their work with the creatures in all of
my good friends back at home and
especially my partner Tanja I send my
love to you